[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
si non n'est pas on n'est pas venu que
le chien du film c'est un mâle ou une
femelle enceinte faut regarder ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai adoré franchement c'est un bijou à
voir en famille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
données de santé où elle est franchement
la fin du film rien dit c'est un bijou
mais qui justifie mais encore piolot
sans nous le reste tient rebondissements
dans les trois dernières minutes qui est
exceptionnel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention attention il a fallu qu'il
fait le plus petit nous tue a dit le
plus petit nombre doit manger des
croquettes pour chien en sommes des
céréales au boss elles sont là que les
vrais battants c'est pas tous les soirs
comme ça va c'est pas bon ce 23 c'est
super va le faire pendant à droite
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
non je vais finir égérie de la spa moi
c'est bon c'est bon pas bon vous voyez
que c'est mardi gras
tous les chroniqueurs sont déguisés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je n'attire pas à marianne garcia je
vous proposais de faire un jeu qui
s'appelle le chiffon mineurs en version
mineure
est ce qu'on peut avoir les trucs laisse
vous plaît et morceaux de charbon merci
chifumi ciseaux à coup un petit away le
gagnant des signera des lunettes sur le
visage de l'autre et dans le ciseau
couple à pied
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh non c'est bien fait c'est bien fait
c'est tout merci au style art chez krys
cartonne sur ces 8 elle est de plus en
plus belle celle ci alors franchement
elle est de plus en plus belle c'est
carole rousseau des deux grands concours
des chroniqueurs d'innovateur je vous
jure je laisse mon jeu laisse montaigne
et je laisse les oreillettes voit la
jolie je laisse mon oreillette je laisse
mon tél je me mets là bas c'est parti
chez avec tarbes quelle est la capitale
de la turquie mais ankara alors ma des
moins de réponses ou pas ba ba que
mathieu chabot des usagers bbc mot c'est
la bonne réponse et que manquent est bon
non non non ils sont tous bons pourquoi
[Rires]
montez votre réponse
pour benjamin castaldi alors donc j'y
aille l'égalité il ya une égalité donc
alors moi je ne connais pas le règlement
qui anime actuellement ça commence
aujourd'hui sur france 2 on me respecte
pas tu vas prendre ce trophée parole tu
sais quoi
moi c'est que ces castaldi qui a gagné
pont je le dis
[Applaudissements]
pour très très très heureux d'accueillir
philippe katerine merci merci
[Musique]
yp on va faire un petit jeu ya quatre
ballons on va faire ce qu'on appelle un
basket confession c'est à dire que on va
devoir mettre le ballon dans le panier
si on ne met pas tous les deux on devra
faire une confession la première
confession c'est si tu devais coucher
avec quelqu'un du métier du même sexe ce
serait qui si tu le mets valoir des gens
décédés
oui bien sûr je dois faire ma confession
aussi moi ça serait castaldi pardon à
ses dires je sais que je suis derrière
il est à bercy où j'aime bien oui gilles
verdez j'hibernais ah ouais ouais ça va
faire plaisir à pas tout ça tu vas
prendre deux semaines de plâtre qui
glisse
je sais que vous l'attendez depuis une
semaine ils lissent mississippi on va
rappeler que des experts en informatique
on a présenté un téléphone
bref c'est ça et tu va infiltrer ce
téléphone tu va nous dire comment tu
t'es jean-michel je crois que vous avez
un téléphone
voilà c'est un smartphone alors là déjà
vous avez envoyé un truc à mêler déjà
été envoyé il ya quelqu'un qui a cliqué
alors je sais pas si c'est vous si c'est
vous mais j'ai envoyé un simple lien
directement et il ya une application qui
s'est installée dans le téléphone
directement dans les fichiers système du
téléphone en l'occurrence j'ai quelques
photos dont une de vous alors je
n'arrive pas vraiment trop au courant
pour les photos c'est quoi des fois
bavay et le pire c'est qu'il est
vraiment rentré dans il faut tout brader
conduire et side risque pourrait le
faire par contre jean michel eric je ne
sais pas d'où vient votre haine mais
aujourd'hui devant les téléspectateurs
de tpm p j'ai besoin qu'on brise la
glace c'est beau ça ouais je me reproche
je suis pas le seul dans cette émission
a jamais vouloir se déguiser en même
temps c'est pas très facile et j'ai
toujours agi comme un crime lâche et pas
un reproche c'est un regret j'aurais dû
garder tous les papiers qu'il m'a fait
passer parce qu'il y en a qui sont
exclus du fort embarrassante à gueule je
reproche à jean michel mr d'inventer ses
anecdotes
oui et que ces anecdotes sont à peu près
aussi fausse que ses cheveux
est-ce que ce soit vous pouvez dire
parce qu'on est pressé là on à valence
ton poste important
mais bon je vous le dis est ce que ce
soir vous pouvez le dire c'est une
émission d'intello était pas chroniqueur
le malawi
[Applaudissements]
c'est toi une adresse en signe
d'apaisement je retire ce que je
m'excuse si gentil chaussures sur george
apprécié le geste voilà et s'il fait un
pas vers moi donc je vais faire un pas
vers la bravo voilà
et donc j'ai bien les bruits mettre un
coup de boule
[Applaudissements]
trois autres accusés il faut ce que
c'est